[Applause]
are we ready
are we ready
yes we are the biggest character in
modern british politics
who in beating his way to number 10.
this whole debate is about democracy
took the country out of the eu
you must stay at home
in office he was confronted with one of
the deadliest challenges ever faced by
any prime minister covid19
but was the downfall of this great
showman that he simply couldn't survive
being seen for who he really was
a liar a showman
a buffoon
a rank incompetent
and probably
the most shameful prime minister that
britain has ever had and somebody the
like of whom i pray we will never see
again i've always liked boris johnson
he's got a real earnest concern for the
british people and they feel it and it's
because they feel it that they love him
so much
well what a tragedy that we've come to
this but we've come to this by his own
hand i'm sorry to say in a way this will
be as always a personal tragedy you know
that the very
many of the factors that brought boris
johnson to be prime minister are also
responsible for his fall
johnson set out in life to be a winner
as a child his stated ambition was world
king and his method self-belief even if
not everything he said was true
as a journalist he was sacked from the
times for misrepresentation and in
politics was sacked again from his first
front bench role for lying about an
affair
but with celebrity appeal and a radar
for popular policy he became london's
first conservative mayor dubbed the
heineken politician reaching parts other
tories couldn't thank you for sticking
up for london and for the innocent
hard-working people of this city
so why not reach number 10
whether he believed in brexit or not
joining vote leave provided a platform
and a policy that appealed to many
grassroots tories and while theresa may
had first stab at delivering brexit
boris johnson is elected as the leader
of the conservative and unionist party
he convinced the tories and then the
electorate that his so-called oven ready
deal was better
i think that his strengths
really lay in campaigning i think had he
picked a
particularly strong team around him
and enabled himself to do more of the
campaigning while others did more of the
governing i think he might still be in
place
his rise had been on the sale of
optimism so his initial approach to the
pandemic was the same i was at a
hospital the other night where i think
there were a few there were actually a
few coronavirus patients and i shook
hands with everybody you'll be pleased
to know accused of being slow to lock
down he succumbed to the virus
meanwhile his controversial advisor
dominic cummings broke the rules then
his apparent rivalry with the prime
minister's new bride carrie johnson led
to him being cut loose instantly
becoming his former boss's fiercest
critic
tens of thousands of people died who
didn't need to die but johnson had got
brexit done albeit with stored-up
problems in northern ireland
his next success was on the vaccine
rollout it was world beating far faster
than the eu he'd won an 80-seat majority
and he'd been quick to support ukraine
against aggression from russia and for
those reasons supporters forgave his
failings for as long as they could his
initial support for owen patterson who
was guilty of lobbying while accepting
cash the donor-funded refurbishment of
his flat above number 11 the number 10
parties during lockdown and the
inconsistencies over what the prime
minister knew nobody said to me this is
an event that is against the rules
still a police investigation fined him
for breaching his own laws he thought he
could play it all as he has all his life
ever since he was a school boy
at eaton he thought he could do it his
own way and he found out and and
many many people said from the very
beginning
that it would go wrong the question was
only when
when deputy chief whip chris pincher
stood down after allegations of sexual
harassment it emerged the pm had been
warned of previous behavior
he denied knowing then when it was clear
he did said he'd forgotten
his chancellor and health secretary had
had enough and set in chain a crumbling
of his support i think he will be
remembered as a great communicator um
you know you know the man that you'd
absolutely delivered brexit but i think
it will also remember somebody that that
fundamentally didn't listen
the man who could reach the parts others
couldn't was plunging to the depths
pulling his party with him
it took a damagingly long time for them
and him
to let go
jason farrell sky news